j'éprouve des problèmes de santé depuis
longtemps récemment j'ai été
diagnostiquée
avec un trouble neurologique très rare
qui a été environ une personne sur un
million et on sait maintenant que c'est
la cause d'espace musculaire dont je
souffle et je ne peux pas toujours
utiliser mes cordes vocales pour chanter
comme je le souhaiterais ça m'attriste
énormément de voir vous dire aujourd'hui
que je ne serai pas prête à recommencer
ma tournée en Europe en février chanter
c'est ce que j'ai fait toute ma vie ne
plus être capable de le faire est
inimaginable je vous aime tellement et
j'espère très très fort pouvoir vous
revoir bientôt
Elisabeth Raynaud est avec nous
biographe de Céline Dion merci
elisabetho vous adore en plus cette
formidable vous êtes un personnage
incroyable et c'est vrai que alors là
Céline Dion on est tous un clé vous la
connaissez bien Céline oui bien sûr
en biographie on a une espèce de
médiumnité avec les gens comme ça
c'est-à-dire
les choses vous sentiez que ça allait
être sérieux sur son histoire
mais moi je voudrais dire quelque chose
si vous me permettez je crois que le
public est un cannibale qui dévore les
artistes et
Céline c'est les cdvorer pendant 30 ans
pendant 30 ans elle a tout donné elle a
elle a donné son âme son corps ses
forces sa vie et puis tout d'un coup
elle a eu un grand coup de un grand coup
de Trafalgar elle a perdu René elle a
perdu sa mère les deux piliers de sa vie
et tout d'un coup les deux piliers
n'étaient plus là et elle s'est écroulée
et puis le corps se révolte son corps se
révolte son corps dit tu m'as tu m'as
traité comme une esclave un esclave
pendant 30 ans et puis maintenant tout
craque alors évidemment ça passe par les
nerfs ça passe par les nerfs ça passe
par les spasmes ça passe par les crampes
les gens tordus les insomnies
l'amaigrissement l'anorexie tout ça
c'est les nerfs alors évidemment on peut
lui donner Cyril tous les noms médicaux
qu'on veut on peut trouver des
appellations elle nous en propose une
pourquoi pas
comment elle a dit le syndrome des
hommes raides ça c'est quand même un
drôle de nom ça qui serait touchant une
personne sur un million
de la personne red c'est un une maladie
du système nerveux central qui a
plusieurs conséquences terribles pour
une chanteuse c'est à dire qu'il y a une
rigidité des membres qui intervient
parfois après des spasmes musculaires et
elle le contrôle plus rien elle ne peut
plus marcher elle ne peut plus contrôler
elle ne peut plus chanter parce que ça
atteint les cordes vocales elle est en
perte d'équilibre et surtout il y a une
hypersensibilité au bruit alors pour une
chanteuse comme elle en concert c'est
absolument impossible ça se matérialise
par quoi je peux pas supporter il ne
peut pas supporter à un moment son
organisme effectivement ne peut plus
supporter le bruit les lumières elle ne
peut plus être stable c'est très
dangereux et surtout c'est une maladie
méconnue qui ne se soigne pas
honnêtement on a très peur qu'elle ne
puisse jamais rechanter parce que son
corps
elle va beaucoup mieux de toute façon
évidemment le système nerveux a été le
premier toucher alors le système nerveux
c'est tout le corps c'est tous les
muscles c'est c'est évidemment la voix
c'est évidemment la façon de se tenir
debout tout son système nerveux a
explosé complètement au moment de ces
deux grandes épreuves
bon sang de bois mais qui est-ce qui
perd l'homme de sa vie et sa mère
de trois années distances sans en être
complètement bouleversé explosé
et c'est vrai que il y a des gens qui
disent ça voilà sur les réseaux et qui
disent alors le public aussi lui il doit
tout donner c'est lui qui a fait son
succès donc c'est le public qui va très
bien enfin entre guillemets par rapport
à ça en tout cas alors que alors que
Céline elle est elle était une devant
une foule à une tête comme on dit qui en
fait dévorait tout ce qu'elle leur
donnait et et elle a été dévorée pendant
30 ans 30 ans 35 ans enfin bon et au
bout de ce temps elle a elle a craqué
elle a craqué il y avait plus rien il y
avait plus rien et aujourd'hui moi je
prétends qu'on peut donner des noms
médicaux à son état actuelle qui n'est
pas si mauvais que ça loin de là mais
tout de même c'est normal c'est normal
que depuis trois ans Céline soit
vraiment en train de payer tout ce
qu'elle a donné pendant 35 ans 30-35 ans
Mathieu ça c'est sûr le problème c'est
que la colère du public c'est que
évidemment il les assurances
gigantesques derrière tout ça qui refuse
le mot annulation parce qu'il faudrait
tout payer donc elle passe son temps à
dire que ce sont des reports depuis deux
ans il faut savoir que les places de
Céline Dion ça va jusqu'à 500 700 750
euros pour les carrés or pour la
rencontrer donc il y a des gens qui ont
fait des efforts gigantesques depuis
deux ans et qui ne sont pas remboursés
par les assurances et qui attendent des
reports qui viennent sans cesse et là
c'est un peu le report de trop parce
qu'elle avait annoncé au mois de juillet
que ça y est elle a attaqué cette
tournée en Europe d'ailleurs vous m'avez
dit dans l'émission que vous vous le
sentiez pas du tout et maintenant elle
reporte de nouveau donc
en septembre non plus de toute façon bon
elle a quand même le don disons avec son
staff de la communication je ne veux pas
être dire
mais elle a le don de la communication
elle s'est reprendre au moment on est
bientôt à Noël on est bientôt au fait de
Noël donc
elle s'est reprendre au bon moment des
des petits messages émouvants ou et ce
n'est pas une comédie j'ai pas dit ça ce
n'est pas une comédie mais elle s'est
bien gérer tout ça